can you please make sure you've got a
arm space for a heading a circle any
circle drawn and a tangent any tangent
to that circle also drawn on there okay
what are you okay now just before just
before we get going on this I want to
point out that circle geometry is kind
of um it's kind of two-faced sort of
character within the mathematics
syllabus because I find it
simultaneously one of the most enraging
and fascinating topics within within
math that you guys have to learn it's
enraging because you all know what it's
like when you look at a diagram and you
ask to prove whatever and you're like I
see nothing I see nothing I drew it I
drew it again and if it's like it's just
not a period to it and that's very
frustrating I get it and I have that
clean memory but one of the reasons why
when you ask me a question and I come to
you a number there it is it's not
because I better at circle geometry than
you it's just I've seen more circle
geometry than you I've had more time
yeah is that oh so here's actually what
I'm going to say right now I mentioned a
couple minutes ago that by the end of
today we'll pretty much have all the
properties categorized far the way that
you will need to know so that means as a
topic circle geometry will be done
however it's really important that after
we finish with circle geometry you
recognize that you are not finished with
circle geometry every time that I've
given you questions and I said okay do
this on this one this one and then I've
let I've left out like vast swaths of an
exercise okay here is my suggestion
talking you to realize this is a good
idea and then when I realized that I
like why haven't I told all of the
students I've ever taught to do this
what you should do is once I finish with
circle geometry I would recommend as we
go through the next tommix topics you
basically do one circle geometry
question just one like a single circle
so we an angle someone having do one air
your time you sit down to do any other
maths homework just do one okay because
you're just doing one it shouldn't take
too much time but secondly because you
keep on doing it regularly you will keep
on flexing that muscle in your brain
that recognizes circles and properties
and that kind of thing I can guarantee
you in 15 months time when you actually
revisit circle geometry again through
the HSC if you spent fifteen months
doing no circle geometry you'll remember
absolutely none of this you need to
regularly do that okay and then it kind
of becomes like riding a bike and like I
haven't so gently since the last planet
or it was just four months ago sorry
more than that and it's still there
because I had that regular practice okay
so that is part of why it's not just for
the sake of time but I'm like okay skip
two thirds of this exercises so you've
got plenty of material you can keep on
working okay right now you've got your
circle and a tangent oh sorry I forgot
to say and this perfectly segues into
what we're about to do so key geometry
can be frustrating but it's also very
playful it's very playful have you
noticed when we prove properties one of
the things I just do is say hey just
draw a circle any circle draw a tangent
anything what I'm about to tell you is
draw a chord here any chord you like so
long as it touches the tangent okay make
sure it's different to the person next
to you where your ruler out pop your arm
pencil on this point of contact and then
draw a chord any chord you like short
chord long chord wherever you want it to
be and what you've done as all chords do
is you have divided up your circle into
two segments right two segments you've
got a minor segment and a major segment
thanks now have a look at that major
segment the one on the left-hand side or
I don't know you might have drawn on the
right hand side doesn't matter which is
one of the cool things others I think we
all agree that any angle funny any angle
we draw in this segment they're all made
the same size yeah
so therefore we can draw any angle we
like right we draw any angle in this
segment they'll all be the same size so
just draw an angle anywhere you like
pick a point on the circumference I'm
going to make it let's see put mine over
here and then join up the angle that's
obtained advisees chord your chord add
the circumference at your chosen point
okay okay now I want you to look really
carefully at the diagram we've just
constructed you've got two tangent
you've got these two segments and then
you've got an angle in this segment over
here I want you to look very carefully
I'm going to mark them in with two
different colors I want you to look very
carefully at the angle between your
tangent and your chord tangent of course
I'm going to mark it in orange now look
at this angle over here and then I want
you to have a look at the angle we've
formed up in that segment over there can
you see it I'm going to put it in green
this guy over here this little carefully
at those angles some of you because
we've been doing circular Murray for
over a week now some of you have
projectors with you so you can actually
measure those angles and even on my
completely freehand diagram you can sort
of see this angle it looks suspiciously
related right and that's why I put it up
what do you think those ankles are I
look pretty cool yeah now the question
of course is I'm going to give you a few
minutes to have a go at this as usual
why why would why would they be equal
it's a very simple diagram why should
that be the case I'll give you some tips
what was the very first shape that we
drew on top of the circle on top of the
circle we drew the tangent right which
is the tangent that was not a
coincidence you know if you know a few
things about tangents right secondly
this is an angle at the circumference
this green one over here you know
actually you know quite a few things
that's hard
because you know so many things about
angles at the circumference that makes
it a little harder to choose from but
you have a whole page in front of you
that outlines and summarize them in a
nice convenient way so the two cloves of
ginyu are there's a tangent there's a
legal in this segment over here the
third tip I'm going to give you is
probably the most succinct proof of this
does require a construction not going to
tell you what it is but I want you to
have a think about it if you know a
construction is necessary where where
might you draw some things okay so I'm
going to pause I'd only you have a few
minutes to have a play with it and see
what you come up with okay